thank you very very much that was overly
long I liked how you you told him to sit
down and the this woman right here in
the front yeah she sat down when you
told her to no one else did so she stood
up and said you stood back up again and
then you you kept doing this and so she
sat down again but still the peer
pressure was too much she stood at this
one of the stripes right here yes yes so
you felt you sat down which was the
correct thing to do when I'm doing this
I really am saying let's get on with the
show she was doing as she was told yes
but then you felt oh my god this looks
bad and you stood up again but then you
sat down and then you stood up again
what is all this yes sir are you in the
army what's the head what's that oh
that's that you respect me as opposed to
everyone else
[Applause]
it's it's a hit Soho fine I think it's
the man next to you yelling she loves
you it's making this all the more art do
we have tissues tissues for God's sake
[Music]
gonna be fine we're getting you tissues
oh wait little candy just as you got
those a woman behind her handed her
tissue oh my god I love that I did this
to try and get to the start of the show
right and here we are 40 minutes later
haven't taken an incredible emotional
journey and Marty shortest seat Martin
Schwartz backstage practicing his stick
and we're screwing around what is your
name oh I didn't want though okay what
and your social security number I will
talk to you Kennedy Kennedy's were nice
to meet you Kennedy it's gonna be a good
show for a nice to meet you we can't be
screwing around anymore there's big news
out there yeah big news Prince Harry and
his wife Megan Marco had their baby this
morning true story the baby is half
British and half American yeah
that means when he grows up he'll Drive
in the middle of the road
[Applause]
now she's crying for a different reason
that's terrible
baby's name has not been revealed yet
oh yeah has not been revealed they'll
have a contest yeah we they don't know
they have not revealed the the baby's
name two names they've ruled out Buddha
edge and Hickenlooper those have been
ruled out that's what the problem is hey
you know what's interesting the the new
baby this is one of the first members of
the British royal family with parents
that are completely unrelated to each
other that's true no that's you think
I'm you're laughing but that is true
because all in you know in the whole
rest of the line pretty much everybody's
distantly related so this is the first
baby that's gene pool it's yeah not
olympic-sized no no yeah first first
baby in the royal family that his
parents are not directly related to each
other which explains why Queen Elizabeth
this morning she looked at the baby and
she said hey look he only has ten toes
Billy's cutting to her for no reason
it's always good after a joke to cut to
a crying woman
[Laughter]